[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
at this point you know who I am you know
about the mission that we came on on
board with about a year and a half ago
so what I'd like to do is talk to you
through patterns that we see in our
account base as far as how their data
science teams are constructed how their
data science teams share work how they
pull in engineering resources are they
centralized or they decentralized and
then talk about a new tool that we
developed based off an acquisition that
we think has automated away a lot of the
very cumbersome things about it sharing
data science research across enterprise
will actually go in the tool and do some
fun stuff with deep learning and some
other frameworks so hopefully you guys
find this interesting
when I talk to a lot of our customers
and specifically for cloud era a lot of
our customers exist in this this g8k we
call it so the global 8000 very large
enterprise usually with you know
assuming mature data science practice
either a nice small group of data
scientists or even in some of the larger
corporations pockets of data science
that are married to these various lines
of business across the organization but
when I'm talking to them and I shown
this slide they generally say that they
can bucket eyes their current directives
in one or two of these buckets and it's
important to understand what the
differences are between these two modes
of data science practice because they
actually come with completely different
skills so I'd say today I haven't met
one of our users that wouldn't they
would say that they're not trying to do
some sort of exploratory data science
today and generally our goal as a
platform provider is really just to give
them as as much as we can self-service
access to that data we want to point the
data scientist at the right data give
them self-service access to it and allow
them to party on the data which is kind
of what we want them to do so
generally in this mode they are using
tools like R and Python
maybe SAS they're working in a notebook
or an IDE environment
I'm so very very compartmentalized
environment versus distributed system
and generally the outputs of their
exercises are our static outputs right
there report they're a dashboard maybe
even they're just a PDF or a PowerPoint
right and so if we can enable those
types of data scientists to get access
to data that lives across the
organization from financial data to
customer data to churn data for a telco
company then we can kind of satiate the
needs of the exploratory data science
mode increasingly though we see a lot of
organizations either today moving
towards an operational mode of data
science or that they have aspirations to
do so and there's a couple key reasons
to why they have this appetite to do so
first and foremost you know when you
think about how you quantify data
science research right it's always been
kind of a very ambiguous task so if I
was a line of business owner and I came
to you and you're the analytics leader
and I said what is your data science
team working on and I say oh they've got
some really great stuff I totally can't
show it to you because you won't
understand it even if I do show it to
you but let me tell you they were at 40%
last week and they are totally at 55%
this week right and it's just this big
amorphous like thing that no one could
judge right but when we start moving to
an operational mode we're actually
delivering models we're producing models
we're producing API endpoints or
embedded application that gives us a
really nice metric on the back end to
say know what is your data science doing
I was like well you know last week we
delivered you know - you know
operational dashboards to the company
and some API endpoints for other
application developers to consume
they're like wow that's great that's a
nice clean number we like nice clean
numbers on the back side you take that
to the in degree and we have people in
the financial services industry that
want to start turning their data science
team into more of a shared service
across the organization so they no
longer want their data science team to
be considered a cost center where
they're putting money into you know very
highly paid PhD graduates but they're
they're actually
to convince the business to purchase
their services across there and you can
think about being an analytics leader
and why that's pretty enticing to you
because you know that really up levels
the strategic nature of how your data
see science team operates and again the
output of these types of exercises
embedded applications API endpoints but
generally the skill set starts to move
more to distributed systems background
right so expertise around Java and Scala
continuous integration things like
integrating with various source control
mechanisms and so this is generally the
mode where it requires a good amount of
interaction between the data engineer
and the data scientists and whether they
sit centrally on the same team or they
cross functionally collaborate across
different teams is really just a design
detail at that point but you really
can't deliver on the promise of
operational analytics operational data
science without you know some sort of
data engineering expertise so you know
again you guys should be intimately
familiar with all of this you know the
the real you know modes of a data
scientists have a lot of times to do
with data preparation the wrangling of
the data any the data munging that has
to happen on the front end the obvious
modelling which tends to be the most
talked about in the sexiest part about
the data science process and then we
might deploy that model maybe depending
on how you know fish in our organization
is but we talked to plenty of companies
Enterprise companies that struggle for
years upon years to deliver a single
model to the organization so it really
shouldn't be viewed as a metric of a
success it should be viewed as a metric
of how those teams are organized and how
efficient you can run as a company so
when I think about this end-to-end
lifecycle of data processing model
development production and I think about
the Hadoop ecosystem I generally like to
say if we're thinking about the
end-to-end lifecycle that
Hadoop as a technology is very helpful
on the far left-hand side of this
diagram
yes left so the ability to ingest and
process large amounts of data in Windows
that are significantly quicker than
previous technologies is a pretty
well-defined canonical Hadoop use case
you don't have to go far with any Hadoop
vendor to understand or find a customer
use case where we've shortened an ETL
window or a data processing window by
orders of magnitude so that's a pretty
well fleshed out use case apache spark
is a very dominant technology there's as
far as our ability to deliver on those
promises I'd also say that Hadoop today
is has some competencies on the
right-hand side of this diagram so once
a models develop the ability to deploy
that model with data stores that have
low latency and high throughput there's
several actual serving mechanisms inside
the Hadoop ecosystem that you can choose
from right so we've got two of the three
areas covered there which really just
leaves us our center section and this is
where all of the features are divided
that I defined all of the initial kind
of data wrangling happening the model
testing and training happens and today
our hypothesis is that this work does
not actually happen on Hadoop is
extracted from other systems and done on
IDE type environments and while this is
the status quo today we believe that is
unidentified
it is a capability to take data out of a
governed repository you put it on a
laptop go on the BART train and leave
your your laptop on the BART train and
therefore you've now exposed your
company's data to malicious people in
any of the IP that you've developed as
part of the model building process right
so there's obviously the secure concern
right we try to sell this vision of a
centralized data platform where
everything is tracked you have full
auditing and lineage across the entire
platform and so if we're extracting data
out of that platform it's really a
nine spot and our ability to track the
full data lineage across all of the
activities that we're doing whether
they're bi related or data science
related so first and foremost in goal
number one was how do we bring that
experience back into the cluster where
we have those governed repositories
where we have that tracking and auditing
and we can allow the data scientists
that direct access to Hadoop data also
another consideration is that when we
extract this data we're always really
dealing with a very small subset of data
right and so when we're doing our model
building we have to make those kind of
generalized assumptions the second big
objective that we had was to improve the
experience between these various areas
so once I've ingested and processed all
of this data how do I make it ready to
the data scientist and give them
self-service access to it and then once
a models developed in an interactive
environment how do I actually push that
model into production distributed
systems without a whole bunch of
refactoring and re-engineering on the
part of other people on my team and
there's some other concerns and they
specifically have to do with the way
that systems interconnect with each
other so one of the things that we hear
pretty often is that generally our data
scientists don't have access to the data
that lives in hadoo whether it's a
security clearance whether it's the
apples of the systems that they're using
they don't have proper access to get
their hands on Hadoop data which
requires an intermediary step between
the data engineer in addition to that
many popular frameworks and libraries
don't read Hadoop date of data formats
out of the box so oftentimes there's a
process to make sure that that data can
be utilized in an IDE environment we
already talked a lot about scale again
small data sets not big data not even
medium data and then many of the popular
frameworks and libraries that exist in
open data in the open data science
ecosystem don't easily parallelizable
Uster the dhoop was designed to be
mostly a Java based system and so when
we start putting things like Python or
distributed R into production there's a
lot of things that don't really work
like we would think they would work in a
distributed fashion and there's a lot of
underlying
mechanisms that are coming up to the
ecosystem that are helping that things
like anaconda parcels to give us a base
level of Python on each one of our data
nodes it allows us to execute Python
code in a way that we can do with
distributed systems languages and then
probably the the biggest pain area was
around the developer experience so one
of the qualms that I have personally
with a lot of the distributed system
technologies out there is that they're
often built by distributed systems
people and trying to fulfill a need from
the Python or our data scientists and
they usually look nothing like an IDE
and they're really just a checkbox item
so if I'm an Enterprise Architect or if
I'm an IT buyer and I ask a Hadoop
vendor hey you know I've got the
scientists that want to write in Python
in our do you have something for them
well we have this little open-source
thing that's not supported at all so yes
we can we can kind of check that
checkbox and then once the data
scientist actually starts working with
it they say hey this looks nothing like
my laptop and one of the hard lessons
that we've learned over the years is
that the affinity is really in the tool
back six or seven years ago when we only
had a handful of BI partners we would go
into an organization say hey you're a
tableau user how do you feel about
MicroStrategy and we would get the
middle finger and walked out of the
organization the affinity is always in
the tool you can't rip the tool out of
the hands of the practitioner in the
same way when we had people starting to
write sequel on Hadoop
we had some very ten gentle ways to do
that and they were generally rejected by
our user base
it wasn't till we developed capabilities
like Hugh and people could write sequel
directly into the Hadoop ecosystem that
people said ok this is something that
I'm that I'm used to and something I'm
familiar with right so we've dealt with
that a lot one additional concern and
probably one of the scarier trends that
we see in the ecosystem today is this
idea of management of dependencies so
let's say for example I have a 15% data
science group inside that 15-person data
science group I have five sass users I
have five Python users and I have five
our users inside those five users of
each individual
you'll technology there are probably
hundreds or hundreds of permutations of
that web version of Python are using 2
dot X 2 dot whatever what types of
libraries do you have installed on those
and so for large organizations that want
to start creating these small
environments for their data scientists
to work they have to create a
permutation of each one of those
environments to accommodate every single
model building activity and this just
tends to proliferate right we start to
see one two three pop up so that starts
to get out of control now we have all of
these permutations of environments all
with different packages deployed all
with different dependencies baked in and
all for a very specific use and then
when we move on to the next use case say
in an operational throw all those
remnants are left behind in I t's kind
of forced to kind of either deprecated
that environment or try to try to
reallocate those resources so while that
is an interim solution it doesn't really
scale to meet the needs of doing all
these types of data science now that's
just in the Python and our ecosystems
all that variation now let's throw in
things like machine learning and deep
learning and now suddenly we have even
more tools that we have to accommodate
none of which the IT organization wants
to support in any type of capacity they
may not even be running the OSS that can
accommodate these types of tools right
so this thing starts to proliferate and
proliferate and proliferate and then
when we start adding deep learning into
the mix it goes even more from there in
fact we did a webinar last week where we
evaluated cafe on SPARC tensorflow DL
Forge a big DL all of these different
permutations many of them very young
some some is early is about 11 months
old right so you can see the blue
wildermann tan AIT organ IT ops eyes
when you go to them and you ask them to
install an open-source project that's
only been available for 11 months with
no enterprise security it'll make the
ped's been around right so how do we
make it to we're in a perfect world the
data scientist brings their tools to the
data whatever tools they want whether
they like Gigi
or matplotlib weather like any type of
visualization software whether it's
Seaborn how do we make it to where we
can deploy purpose-built environments
that they're intimately synchronized
with the Hadoop ecosystem
all of the data stores and hadoo all of
the access engines like Apache spark and
Impala and otherwise and how do we make
it to where we bring the data scientists
directly that data and for the IT
counterpart how do we allow them to do
this on existing infrastructure they're
using Hadoop today to accommodate their
analytic database they got bi people
using the system they got DBAs
understanding what the query workloads
are and transferring stuff off their
enterprise data warehouse on to do how
do we now bring the data scientists into
the fold and say I see you can give them
all of those permutations of
environments that they asked for
without interjecting any additional risk
to you or any operational overhead and
managing all of those different
environments so roughly about one year
ago from today we acquired a small but
productive company called cents since
was a software as a service platform
where data scientists could collaborate
on code and Python and our they could
launch models they could produce models
as API endpoints and very like like nice
siloed ways but there wasn't into there
wasn't anything intimately Hadoop
related about the technology so in the
past year we have re-engineered the data
science workbench under this hypothesis
that we didn't want to make another
notebook another proprietary way to work
with data we think the data scientists
love the know the notebook experience
but we wanted to solve all those issues
that we talked about around into in data
science the management of dependencies
the security when connecting to
kerberized clusters so in Hadoop today
if we were to chop up the kind of
conflated definition of a data scientist
today we really want to accommodate all
circles of the sindh diagram right so
for our domain expertise we have tons of
drag and drop tools that allow you to
visually take an algorithm apply it to a
subset of data do some parameter tuning
and get the types of effects that you
need and so for data scientists that are
more on the quantitative research side
that maybe don't have any coding
background they can work on the Hadoop
ecosystem today now when we have and
I'll skip to the last one when we have
on the left hand side we have the people
that have that very nice pollination of
distributed systems knowledge and
statistical programming skills and for
them our assumption is they're using
Hadoop today they're using things like
Apache spark they're writing distributed
systems language so the real underserved
part of the market that we needed to
develop a solution for was this middle
section here right for the people that
want to write in Python are that don't
necessarily want to be distributed
systems people and so for that we built
something called the data science
workbench data science Berg workbench is
a secure self-service environment for
code enrichment for the building of
machine learning models directly on
Hadoop data it has some workflow
automation some pipeline buildings and
stuff like that basically a lot of
different mechanisms and everything is
in there is thought out to ensure that
we're giving more self-service access to
the data scientist and it helps in
various ways you can visualize the
results you can have multiple users on
the same platform you can have
extensible engines basically creating
those very specific environments for
your data scientists and it incorporates
very widely with all the other ecosystem
tools out there whether there are studio
or otherwise so now we're going to get
to our demo I thought it'd be fun today
for us to plot all of the casualties of
the bowling-green massacre I think
that's it I think that's the end of the
demo oh wait there's one Kelly and
Conway's career thanks for the talk so
questions about where the kernels
actually live so do they live inside a
yarn we try to put docker containers and
yarn before that didn't work very well
yeah I'm not even sure if it's possible
at this point
so where do they live so in this one in
great question by the way
so darker on yarn is still kind of an
interesting project for us a couple
things there docker requires Red Hat 7.2
I believe yeah 7.2 and not many of the
people that run very large-scale Hadoop
clusters are running redhead at all on
that cluster or more specifically Red
Hat version 7.2 so we had two choices
when building this product right we
could utilize something like docker on
yarn which would be the ideal use case
because then all the resources that we
need are plentiful and available at any
given time however the way that we
designed it is that there's a series of
edge nodes that have dr. and kubernetes
kubernetes is the mechanism to deploy
the resources to those individual
document acres that solves a crucial
problem for us it makes sure that the
edge nodes only have to run Red Hat
version 7.2 and then anything across the
cluster can run CentOS or whatever our
heart desires basically and over time we
plan to migrate to docker on yarn once
we feel that OS level requirements
generally kind of catch up okay so that
would be the model for your customers
moving forward to not have two different
resource negotiators there Sivan totally
funny thing was kubernetes actually
works really good
it's like specifically for this use case
like we got on there thinking I was like
well this is just going to be a hack
until we can get darker on yarn working
and like realistically it kind of does
everything we need to do today but the
bummer about it is you kind of have to
know how many data scientists and how
many workloads you expect in order to
size out your edge node configuration to
accommodate that so that's kind of
cumbersome generally we've seen those
resources to be pretty meager so it
hasn't been a huge deal but you start to
getting like the hundreds of data
scientists like actually our initial
customer for this was the Office of
National Statistics and the UK and they
ported 150 Jupiter notebooks into this
tool and so they gave us a real quick
burnin of all of these scale
capabilities and it you know kubernetes
did a bang-up job like cooed kudos to
kubernetes yes